for people who don't know you're are you
from Stockton Stockton yeah so the 209
is a very serious place people don't
understand it like that's why they were
talking about how ruthless the industry
is Stockton's crazy yeah it's a lot my
manager Brian Sampson is from Stockton
right I mean unfortunately for both of
us and uh one day he convinced me to not
take us a flight home from San Francisco
because I was going to fly from San
Francisco back to Burbank
and he was driving and he was like bro I
don't want to drive alone just just
drive with me you know you'll get you'll
get there in the morning so I'm like
fine I'll go with you to Stockton no no
no we're supposed to drive from the bay
back to LA okay so I pass out in the
front seat and I wake up in the middle
of the [__]
The Trenches of Stockton while he's
giving me an unvolunteered like Hood
Vlog tour at like one in the morning
and it yeah it's a rough place man
Stockton serious tell me a little bit
about just like a childhood growing up
man yeah Brian's a HomeTown hero too
because even earlier in my you know when
I was before the industry I always heard
of he would always he did great making
it to La working in the music business
and then he would always go home and DJ
fly and he would give people hope that
they could make it in the business but
um and I don't have a relationship with
them I just know them of course good
luck lucky for you by the way Stockton
is great I mean you know even though
it's a difficult City I really feel like
it's it has its challenges like most
inner city communities around the world
around the country
um I grew up with a white mom and a
black father who was always married to
his wife she just passed away a couple
weeks ago and you know I didn't have a
relationship with them the way that I
had with my mom but um you know I was a
product of my community I I tried to
sell drugs wasn't good at that got shot
watched my brother get murdered had lots
of friends die I was talking to my
friend the other day that when I think
about how many people died in the year
of just 1997 alone my brother tons of
friends I was almost at a funeral every
other week for like three or four months
and uh and I'm and I really look at
Stockton as
um the place where I first got my um
interest in the business I met Queen
Latifah that that light that I did that
I could be more than my my community was
there but now I'm back building my
foundation and working with my mayor my
city council to launch an initiative
called the I'm ready initiative where
we're going to Target black and brown
kids to bring in all the people I built
the relationship with to create
programming and you know Zoom meetings
and stuff with these kids to give them
hope but then embedded in that is a lot
of Behavioral change and programming
systemic changes that they have to make
in order to be eligible so I'm excited I
don't see I know the narrative about
Stockton and it's true it is dangerous
um but there's also so much hope there
and I always look at an opportunity
where okay yeah it may be [__] up but
if the right people care enough then
they'll do what it takes to make it
better yeah it seems like a lot of
upcoming artists like have died recently
um it's rough man there's like super
dope thriving Hip-Hops to me Stockton is
like the most exciting scene in hip-hop
in like in California oh really it's
bubbling yeah I'm not as tapped in on
the music it's it's lit yeah shout out
to everybody doing their thing out there
we had uh the Haiti baby do you know who
of course of course the freestyle on our
show that went viral no no because of
you I saw him and then he came on my
show and I think he came on my show at a
time where he wasn't really ready to do
media because he was just new yeah but
he's super talented and and now that
I've seen him grow and come to LA and
I've had lunch with him in um and met
him again very articulate super solid
dude man very good person and he had
these very talented and I know a lot of
people who man are watching him yeah
Jeezy just uh he just signed a CTE with
cheesy oh nice so congrats to him